all right Ivana is in Los Angeles hey
Ivana what's up hey thanks for taking my
call I'm calling because I would like
your advice so my husband has some
private loans to a college she went to
for $12,000 but because of the interest
being a dollar seventy seven a day we
know thirteen thousand seven hundred and
we have a little income we make around
2800 a month
we're both full-time students when we
both work we're trying to negotiate the
interest because it's becoming
overwhelming what can you offer us as a
vise I mean you have a contract with
them for the interest they have no
reason to negotiate it's not it's not
overwhelming mathematically it might be
overwhelming emotionally you should have
got it you sure I've got it dialed in in
your brain for sure when you start tell
me how much it is a day I haven't had
that call in years the but the good news
is is only twelve thirteen thousand
bucks so what do you guys you're both
studying for what bachelor's degrees I'm
sorry what are you studying
I'm studying early childhood education
and he's studying electrical engineering
and when do you graduate he graduated in
2013 from a tech school for MRI and he
he he is just not doing well with MRI he
does not like it she wants to become
something else where he's got $12,000
debt that's overwhelming his wife he
needs to go do like a bazillion MRIs in
the next two months and pay this loan
off okay here's the thing if it was a
hundred and eighty thousand dollars and
it was going up eighteen thousand
dollars a minute that starts to be
overwhelming because it's really hard to
create an income for most people that
can fix that $1,000 a month makes this
whole thing go away yeah what we're
doing is we were just we we're eating
rice and beans
we don't have fancy phones or anything
I'm talking about income oh yes here's a
less than three thousand his income his
income right now alone is not much 2000
month yeah yeah and so work more mm-hmm
earn more money it's only a thousand
thousand bucks and what this whole thing
is gone in here yeah the whole problem
it's not overwhelming it's really not it
you all you got to do is you know he
just got deliver pizzas for five nights
a week okay and knock it out and you'll
be done and knock you just be completely
done with these people never borrow
money for that again I don't mind that
he moves from MRI and engineering or
moves whatever direction he wants to go
I don't have any issue with that but
you're trying to fix this on the wrong
end it's not an interest rate problem
it's an income problem it's not a debt
problem it's an income problem cuz it's
not much it dad it's not much interest
rate so the you know you can do it you
you know you ober drive you can you can
pay this off you deliver pizzas you can
pay this off if you can do MRIs you can
make more doing that than either one of
those other two things so I suggest
picking up some weekends at the you know
the ER or whatever wherever it is he can
gets paid some good bucks for doing MRIs
and it's not what he wants to with this
whole life but he but while we're trying
to is temporarily I mean go make five or
six thousand bucks makes this thing go
away pop it in the head you know knock
it that that's what your deal is and so
that way you don't worry about a dollar
seventy seven dollar seventy seven eight
you know it's nothing if you're working
and make it more money that's what you
gotta do on a temporary basis clean this
mess up
hey thank you for listening kiddo this
is the Dave Ramsey show